not far from the white house america's
20 years in afghanistan is reflected
here arlington cemetery the cost of this
war on one patch of grass
this is the context in which a
presidential pledge to end the war to
bring the troops home was made
and yet now the consequence of a
decision in washington chaos and
accusations of abandonment both of
principles and people this looks like a
chaotic the secretary of state's message
seems to be we thought the afghan
government could defend themselves
it turned out they couldn't
the fact is we invested the
international community invested over 20
years billions of dollars in these
forces three hundred thousand of them uh
with an air force something the taliban
uh didn't have with the most modern uh
sophisticated equipment and
unfortunately uh tragically they have
not been able uh to defend the country
the president is not here in washington
he was on holiday at the camp david
retreat when all this unfolded and he
remains there this image released by his
staff is all we've seen of him we're
told he is being continually briefed on
the consequences of a decision he says
he does not regret there are several
urgent challenges right now for
president biden most pressing is the
situation on the ground the security and
the unfolding humanitarian crisis just
how on earth to manage that and then
there are the wider implications what
does this mean for afghanistan and what
does it say about america
the roots of all this are of course here
911 an attack by a terror group who was
protected by the taliban president bush
invaded afghanistan the terror threat
and the taliban were removed
the administration insists that the
terror threat will not re-emerge now and
yet the last few days suggest american
assumptions have been wrong at every
turn
how did that happen
i am puzzled by how this happened
clearly the taliban have been using the
past several years of supposed
negotiations
to prepare for a military takeover in
short america was duped these peace
talks in doha allowed the release of
taliban prisoners america stopped its
airstrikes
for taliban assurances of power sharing
of peace well they were it turns out a
veneer
now for the first time in 20 years the
taliban and all that they represent are
back